[Musique]
devenu dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
avec un sommaire très chargé puisque
l'actualité vous le savez les taux si on
veut parler de l'islamo gauchisme à
l'université existe-t-il vraiment un
fantasme on va parler des affaires de
viol et qui se répandent dans la presse
des rapports difficiles entre les médias
les justices on va parler aussi d'eric
zemmour dont on dit qu'il pourrait être
candidat à la présidence de la
république qui pour en parler en plateau
laurent mazaury bonjour bonjour asim
accueillir régler très vite tout à fait
ravis vous êtes vous êtes adjoint au
maire d'elancourt vice président de
saint quentin en yvelines et président
de tv 78 c'est tout dit tout à fait prêt
et contribué et contribuent pas à vous a
perdu je sers d'un génie bonjour bonjour
vous êtes toujours éviterait un jour
avec robin on te dirai peut-être un mot
de lettres mortes
bah oui en fin d'émission très très bon
bouquin d'une jeune toulousaine est avec
nous au visio à xiamen bezina duclair
bonjour bonjour patrice ça va bien ça va
bien alors vous êtes maître de
conférences à l'université de zorro
ah oui toujours vincent couronne bonjour
bonjour patrice ça va bien vous êtes le
fondateur des studios lignières et je
sais bien que tous les vendredis
d'ailleurs on passe une formidable
chronique où vous remettez de l'ordre
dans l'est dans les discours des
politiques qui sont souvent faux et puis
jean baptiste dupuy un bon jour pendant
batterie êtes vous aussi toujours maître
de conférences à l'université de
versailles saint quentin
alors on va commencer peut-être par un
quelque chose qui s'est passé qui
concerne une députée des yvelines qui
est aussi le président de la commission
des lois à l'assemblée qui est il ya une
brawn pie v et qui a subi des attaques
antisémites absolument terrible on la
traite de youpine on lui prépare toi
bientôt des camps à nouveau c'est quand
même assez assez incroyable on va
l'écouter on a serré ses réactions
qu'elle nous a donné vendredi
c'est toujours en fait la boule au
ventre qui ne s'estompe pas parce que
c'est extrêmement violent c'est indigne
on a du mal à imaginer qu'aujourd'hui on
va avoir ce type de message en 2020
terre d'antisémitisme et comme toute
forme de racisme est absolument
incompréhensible et qu'elle skiffs que
ça puisse encore aujourd'hui s'exprimer
aussi aussi clairement c'est c'est
effrayant et c'est ça qui fait que
effectivement ça ne passe pas en
revanche ce qui est absolument
formidable c'est l'unité républicaine
qui s'est immédiatement manifesté soit
hier dans l'hémicycle où depuis où je
reçois des messages soient d'élus soit
de citoyens qui expriment leur soutien
mais voilà alors c'est vrai qu'il y
aller il ya les deux choses c'est à dire
on est assez même je sais pas terrassé
quand on entend des mots comme ça qu'on
n'entendait plus des gouttes des ayew
pin
c'est même extrêmement difficile a
commenté parce que je veux dire les bras
nous en tombent on dit mais
manifestement sais pas d'où ça vient
avant donc c'est très difficile en effet
mais c'est très compliqué mais c'est
juste immonde ignoble enfin y'a pas de
mots c'est effectivement c'est ridicule
ça doit être absolument monstrueux pour
cette femme et c'est très bien que la
représentation nationale ce soit ait
fait bloc
ça serait bien que tout le monde fasse
bloc derrière et j'espère qu'il aura pas
encore une fois des gens qui vont dire
oui mais mais c'est pas tout à fait mais
faut voir faut étudier ne nous dépêchons
pas ne stigmatisons pas tu vois là il
faudrait vraiment que que tout le monde
prenne la mesure de l'événement c'est
que c'est à dire qu' une seule parole
antisémite
une seule fois ce mot horrible de
prononcé c'est inadmissible on
ne signale pas de dégâts pas de vrai et
le parquet a d'ailleurs lancé une
enquête à la tuque oui voila je viens à
part lui l'émotion qu'on peut ressentir
l'indignation la condamnation définitive
quels que soient les auteurs j'espère
qu'ils seront identifiés et lourdement
sanctionné lourdement condamné parce que
on retrouve là des expressions de la rue
malheureusement qu'on entend parfois
faut le savoir la sa frappe une députée
mais on entend ce genre de propos est
compris parfois dans nos communes et
dont il faut sanctionner
systématiquement peu apporte tout cela
vienne et bien entendu exprimer notre
solidarité avec ces députés bref
n'importe quelle autre personne qui
subissent de tels propos
l'antisémitisme en plus c'est une
question qui revient de façon récurrente
avec naturellement plusieurs sortes
d'antisémitisme l'antisémitisme
un pot culturel qui a été lancée
sémitisme religieux catholiques français
en gros quelqu'un qui a été très fort
dans notre société c'est la sphère
prépuce et puis il ya un antisémitisme
nouveau qui tient aussi au conflit
israélo-palestinien en gros c'est un peu
ça et là on va retrouver peut-être sur
le sujet suivant qui est l'islamo
gauchisme playlist certaine gêne
sur ces sujets quelques uns veulent
intervenir ou peut-être un mot patrice
je trouve que c'est aussi ça témoigne
aussi du fait que dès lors qu'on n'y
prête pas trop attention
la bâtiment de ressurgit et s'il faut
actuellement lutter contre ça je signale
simplement que la justice dès lors qu'il
ya une violation de la loi et il semble
ici que ce soit quand même assez clair
peut mettre à bas l'anonymat des
personnes qui profèrent ce genre de
menaces sur les réseaux sociaux et qu'il
n'ya pas d'anonymat total sur les
réseaux sociaux et que la justice
peuvent poursuivre et condamner ce genre
de ce genre de personne et donc j'espère
qu'elle le fera ici là c'est venu d'un
mail je crois qu'elle est élevée enfin
c'est dans des faits c'est d'une
certaine façon des réseaux sociaux
enfin on va passer alors ça m'intéresse
de savoir si est ce que ça vous drogue
se trouvait ça normal
ben c'est nicolas sarkozy qui a 66 ans
donc il ne rentre pas dans les
catégories qui devraient être vaccinés
qui a été vaccinée en mois de janvier en
rien au bout d'abord laurent ça vous
choque
vous trouvez ça normal je sais pas si ça
me choque ça me choque pas forcément en
réalité mais j'aurais plutôt un point
j'ai trouvé que cette question était
posée par un journaliste omise de la
santé dans sa conférence de presse
qu'elle suivit la révélation de cet
événement et j'aurais que sa réponse est
assez juste la première chose c'est que
tout le monde a droit au secret médical
et donc par conséquent on devrait
supposer que si nicolas sarkozy a été
descellé c'est peut-être un désert
médical que l'on ignore et du coup on
pourrait se poser la question de savoir
mais c'est de secret médical quand il
était présent dans le public et c'est
toute la question de l'anonymat de
l'état de santé du président de
république si quelque chose pouvait
justifier donc à ce stade moi je
resterai là après juste pour faire très
court on peut aussi se poser la question
de doit-on vacciner des élites etc
auxquels cartes et jean a tendance à
penser de acceptant des hits qui sont au
pouvoir et actif que des hits qui ne le
sont plus du coup il ne rentrerait pas
dans cette catégorie
donc je vais supposer qu'ils aient une
raison médicale et moi je m'arrêterai là
au niveau de ce commentaire nous sommes
déjà qu'il faut protéger notre stock
d'anciens présidents donc qui diminue
y'a que oui voilà donc deux il nous en
reste deux garçons relativement je mets
donc conservons les cerfs-volants des
messines ont bien évidemment je trouve
ça très bien je veux dire ça une valeur
d'exemple c'est quand même un ancien
taulard accumulé le plus de gens qui
sauf que ça n'a pas été fait
publiquement s'est passé pas quelqu'un
qui est dit voilà je vous montrais on ne
doit pas avoir peur du vaccin jeu il n'a
pas il n'a pas donné de publicité à
cette vaccination donc oui la valeur
d'exemple elle l'est un peu on peut la
contester
on va venir observer puis tous choqués
même si bon évidemment tout le monde a
le droit à sa vaccination et à son
secret médical ça c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut rappeler secret d'instruction
secret médical secret en général qui
avec cette vague de transparence sont
tellement malmené mais oui plutôt
choquée parce qu'à partir du moment où
on a le sentiment qu'on rompe principe
d'égalité et que on nous donne une
politique générale qui consiste à dire
voilà telle tranche d'âge 8 elle tranche
d'âge non on respecte à partir du moment
où il ya de l'exemplarité et là je crois
qu'il ya quelque chose qu'on n'arrive
pas à identifier alors peut-être la
raison médicale secrète mais sans cela
oui assez choqué vincent couronne oui je
suis d'accord avec un de charlene je
suis plutôt plutôt choqués de cet
épisode là ça a été fait si ça avait été
fait publiquement pour une campagne de
promotion de la vaccination etc
mais nicolas sarkozy est un ancien
président public ce n'est certes pas un
citoyen tout à fait comme les autres du
fait de ce statut mais il n'empêche que
il n'a plus à voir n'a pas nous sommes à
avoir des privilèges particuliers en
tout cas sur les questions sur ces
questions médicales
sauf si comme le dit laurent lazoore il
il ya des lots médicale le président
président du cler oui effectivement je
crois qu'à partir du moment qu'on ne
sont pas véritablement l'information
puisque ses couverts par le secret on
est donc dans l'expectative
j'aurais plutôt à penser que si le
secret médical est à danser c'est un
médecin s'est produit c'est que
vraisemblablement il
médicales alors j'espère évidemment
impérieuse jusqu'ici effectivement
quiscales à se faire vacciner
après en tout cas c'est vrai que cette
question elle dénote aussi de cette
passion égalitariste qui nous aussi et
qui est gênant que prononcer encore
poussé l'air lorsqu'il s'agit des 1113
oui oui ça y est cette passion de
l'égalité alors salé ni s'était
intéressé aussi parce que si on se
projette dans l'avenir supposons que par
des circonstances nicolas sarkozy se
soit amené à se représenter
la présence d'un public il faudra bien
levé le secret médical
à ce moment là parce que ça pourrait
poser un problème justement c'est bien
pour quelqu'un qui est vaccinés oui mais
si les vacciner pour des réseaux de bord
de cobourne idéal mais admettons puisque
rentrer dans ces raisons de n'ont
peut-être pas de comorbidité ortega de
raisons de pouvoir les priorités 2010
c'est parce que c'est le thème
voilà maintenant je l'aimé mais
peut-être qu'il aa les et diabète touche
par cas qui n'a aucune importance
il ya cinquante mille raisons qui font
que et c'est tout à fait probablement
justifiée et puis qu'importe ce derby
il ya aussi un côté un peu ridicule et
ce qu'on emmènerait autant un quelqu'un
d'autre que nicolas sarkozy non l'a fait
parce que y'a vraiment c'est une espèce
de frénésie française pourra tout de
suite dès que sarkozy fait quelque chose
tout était opposant les gens assez mal
ces masses et de reconnaissance a dit
l'ex président normal c'est à dire
françois bellot mr nicolas sarkozy c'est
nicolas sarkozy qui est vacciné par le
reste de la france dans le cas du
président de l'andp par contre la france
est bien vacciné dû briser hollande
on a beaucoup moins de risques je
dansais enfin voulait ajouter un mot
là-dessus
charlene a peut-être pour dire que je
suis pas sûr que s'ils deviennent à
nouveau président on ait besoin de
connaître son état de santé non plus moi
j'étais personnellement assez hostile à
tous les bulletins réguliers des manuels
macron à la durant la période où il a
été positif
ça relève du secret pour n'importe quel
être humain la seule chose c'est qu'ici
on a vraiment le sentiment qu'il ya une
rupture parce qu'on comprend pas
pourquoi cette exorbitants 6,6 pour
quelqu'un qui a un titre en plus ça
paraît assez choquant mais et la santé
du président comme n'importe quel autre
santé mais
in d'être à mon avis protéger dans son
secret je suis pas choqué par ça en tout
cas mais c'est vrai que la tradition
veut maintenant depuis depuis georges
pour vidéo évidemment quand on donne des
butins de santé qui sont vrais ou faux
on l'avait vu notamment avec françois
mitterrand qui a été pendant des années
et des années a que ça qui à défaut d
ailleurs vassard particulier chirac
quand il s'est étalé au val de grâce et
que même son ministre de l'intérieur est
au courant enfin je tiens une affichage
comme ça de transparence qui n'hésite
pas toujours la réalité
on va passer aux gros plan c'est à dire
la justice et des médias en matière
d'inceste et de viol
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors c'est vrai que l'on voit chaque
jour dans la presse ces nouvelles
histoires à faire ou d'inceste ou de
viols des révélations des accusations et
des avocats ont fait une tribune dans
dont hervé temime notamment au fait
d'une tribune dans le monde pour
regretter justement que les médias se
dresse en justicier parce que c'est vrai
que les gens qui sont mis en cause dans
la presse très difficile pour eux
ensuite de se défendre
ils sont médiatiquement mort billy ray
les excès se terminer jeudi à montréal
par exemple qu' il y avait un film avec
richard berry qui devait passer à la
télévision qui était déprogrammé
et puis jamais par exemple parisien qui
a fait hier fauves entière 2 pas sûr que
péter elle fera jamais de pages pour
dire bah finalement que ppda ne
mais n'est coupable de rien donc le mal
est fait on jette les gens en pâture à
une opinion publique qui s'emmerdent un
peu piqué toujours une fois ces vaccins
de sarkozy ce n'est pas très grave mais
là maintenant c'est plus pdac richard
berry c'est là on a vu les dégâts
l'ancien patron d'equidia eric brion je
veux dire ktk perdu son boulot mais
qu'elle a été totalement innocentée de
tout mais je veux dire voilà ce qu'il a
fait de sa vie est foutue
sa vie est foutue donc alors et en même
temps il ya ce besoin d' écoute de la
parole des victimes une certaine vision
du club peut-être en fait je dirais
qu'il ya deux impératifs ici c'est à
dire qu'il ya un impératif de vérité
celui de lui celui qui doit être vu du
côté d'un victimes de parler donc c'est
à dire cette fameuse loi du silence qui
doit être brisé on en a parlé dans le
sport on en a parlé dans le cinéma on en
parle aujourd'hui dans tous les secteurs
est et à ce titre là je crois que ça ne
peut être que saluée c'est à dire se
dire enfin tout ce qui peut consister en
une loi de l'omerta en une incitation au
silence pour acquérir des passe-droits
et c'est tout ça doit évidemment cessé
dans cette société de la transparence et
de la moralisation on ne peut
qu'accueillir manière bienveillante une
parole qui se libère néanmoins c'était
notamment boris cyrulnik qui disait cela
parole qui berce et c'est ça reste une
parole et je crois qu'on ne devrait pas
oublier que la justice est normalement
là pour permettre la justice c'est à
dire l'égalité entre les parties et
permettre aussi qu'il puisse y avoir une
défense seul problème c'est vrai que
cette justice se prescrit par le temps
donc très souvent malheureusement on a
affaire à des affaires qui m'ont remonte
alors est ce que il ya prescription non
ça dépend aussi de l'ordre du crime
sexuel qui a été qui est qui est en
cause
donc voilà est-ce que la justice est la
bonne réponse moi j'ai tendance à penser
qu'en tout cas elle permet plus de
garanties mais sur le principe du
discours qui se libère je crois qu'on
peut être qu une anim là dessus sur le
fait de le soutenir alors c'est
paradoxal
vincent couronne oui c'est vrai que il
ya cette tendance perdure
c'est ce que disait
un puncheur l'aisne latos maintenant qui
est de croire les victimes sur parole
oui alors en effet en fait on a déjà eu
lors du mouvement mitu balances ton
corps des tribunaux si qui dénonçait le
tribunal médiatique etc et ce genre de
choses il ya forcément des excès en fait
dans ce genre de mouvement simplement et
il faut le vivre pour le dénoncer et le
regretter bien évidemment simplement si
en fait ça s'exprime par sam comment
dire cette parole se libère par cette
voie là c'est parce qu'en fait il ya pas
de canal qui d'autre canal qui
fonctionne convenablement en fait donc
forcément il ya des victimes
collatérales
il ya des dégâts collatéraux avec cette
ce tribunal médiatique inquiets comme le
disait le magistrat denis salas ce une
sorte de justice en circuit court parce
que elle permet de donner une
satisfaction quasi immédiate à la
victime
le problème c'est que si ça peut
fonctionner pendant un temps court en
fait ça ne peut être que sur
l'accusation mais le jugement ne doit
rester entre les mains de la justice
il ne faut pas déligitimer la justice au
risque en fait de priver les vraies
victimes des vrais moyens pour lutter
contre contre ce phénomène
donc il ya une prise de parole une
libération une libération de la parole à
ces comment dire forte au début dans les
médias c'est une bonne chose mais il
faut aussi reconnaître les limites et qu
on est tous collectivement conscience
qu'il n'y a qu'au la justice qui est en
mesure de dire qui est coupable et qui
ne l'est pas simplement je me demande
parfois si ça n'est pas l'effet
recherché par ces victimes là puisque
souvent il s'agit de personnes célèbres
et donc du coup est ce qu'il n'ya pas
envie de taper là où ça fait mal un
petit peu en tout cas si on prend par
exemple le discours de camille kouchner
on a le sentiment quand elle s'exprime
qu'elle ne disait assez clairement en
disant j'ai choisi ce média là parce que
je voulais que la l'insécurité que moi
je vivais se bascule de son côté il n'y
avait qu ici que quelque part je pouvais
avoir l'impact que je souhaitais donc
c'est ça la question aussi c'est la
justice oui mais la justice elle reste
finalement assez secrète et encore
heureux bien sûr et finalement est ce
que la maintenant dans ce fameux
tribunal médiatique ce n'est pas l'effet
recherché par les victimes c'est à dire
une forme de vengeance finalement par la
réputation et c'est ça qui a la foi est
dangereux il mérite d'être saisi comment
arriver à donner à donner du sens à ce
besoin de blessés finalement qui vient
de l'atteinte à l'honneur qui a été fait
donc c'est ça qui est à mon avis je me
demande si ça n'est pas l'effet
recherché ces salles à la réflexion que
j'ai il ya probablement une pas une part
de sa vie en france assure tendance à
considérer que le petit a toujours
raison contre le grand le pauvre contre
le riche le lundi la libération de la
parole et c'est quand même quelque chose
d'important aussi dans ses attaques
contre la vedette l'acteur bon bah je
vais aussi beau 15 ans
quinze ans après je veux dire c'est
cette jeune femme que tout le monde nous
présente comme un romancier une
romancière et en écrivant faut pas dire
que les bleus manière générale parce que
dans les faits chaque les affaires ce
décalage est quand même un peu choquant
mais moi ça me semble gène vrai qu'on se
rappelle d'affaires du passé on sait
qu'on savait très bien mis à tiques
je pense à la sphère dominique baudis
dont l'omni camille je sais pas quinze
ans à à ce qu'on entend qu'il n'était
pas coupable alors que pourtant ils
avaient devils et pas coupable et je
pense de petits entre deux petits je
pense à la ferme ou trop à outreau je
rappel c'est la parole d'enfants et
simplement parce que effectivement de
fait c'était des victimes et que de fait
c'était des enfants
forcément il ou elle a laissé seul un
juge a été alors aimer mais je pense que
la partie mais la partie médiatique a
fini par influencer le juge et qui
forcément instrumentalisé et instruit le
dossier à charge donc voilà ce sur quoi
je souhaite que l'on a si c'est que pour
moi seule la justice peut rendre une
décision juste mais je dirais que c'est
une justice qui doit avoir les bonnes
informations
ça c'est le premier point et
deuxièmement attention à la rapidité de
la décision
c'est à dire qu'effectivement la parole
se libère et par conséquent le tribunal
médiatique a tendance à contenir
rapidement dans une haie de se dire il
faut rapidement condamnés même quand sur
des faits qui sont 13 ans
tiens mais je rappelle quand même que si
on n'a pas la force de la preuve je ne
vois pas au nom de quoi on peut
condamner et que le premier élément
c'est d'avoir une preuve est là où
peut-être le fait que la parole se
libère peu à voir quelque chose de
positif c'est si on est capable de faire
en sorte que justement la victime puisse
rapidement porté plainte
et là effectivement perdre des éléments
de preuve mais 15 ans 20 ans et pourquoi
pas reporter la prescription à 40 ans
comment on peut tomber le truc et que 40
ans plus tard on puisse avoir des
éléments de preuve de quelque chose qui
sait peut-être pas c'est vrai mais
peut-être pas et pour terminer on voit
bien également que effectivement il ya
un côté c'est horrible parce que même si
c'est vrai il ya quand même un côté
exploitation business dans tout ça
bizarrement un livre claude hamelin et
j'espère qu'il ya pas quelque part un
tableau excel qui existent pardon cher
ami éditeur chez certains éditeurs qui
se disent moi quand je déclenche tel
scandale l'impact sur les ventes c'est
ça et donc je vais prendre un legs il va
écrire le livre et puis je vais aussi
faire des clins d'oeil au scandale et du
coup ça comme les vraies victimes
il est probable que le roman de la jeune
femme qui épuise pdf vaut mieux que si
cette affaire mais la kizomba c'est
parce que ça mais c'est email et quant à
l' affaire d'outreau vous avez raison de
rappeler c'est vrai que ça venait juste
après l affaire dutroux est ce donc la
pédophilie était le crime le plus
terrible soir et tôt le juge a dû être
influencé par sept par sa mairie
c'est par tous les médias enfin mûri je
suis musulman jean baptiste duclair
justement à interviennent disais tout à
l'heure il y avait peut-être un désir de
vengeance de la part des gens qui
dénoncent ces probables et mais c'est
vrai aussi que ces affaires sont
prescrites donc ils n'ont plus tellement
le recours de la justice qu'est ce que
vous pensez de il ya tout un mouvement
qui dit il faudrait arrêter la
prescription sur ces crimes
qu'est ce que vous en pensez sur la
prescription
déjà elle est intéressant parce qu'elle
dit quelque chose de notre société si on
replace la question d'un resto timité à
l'échelle de l'histoire on observe qu'en
fait ce qui est en son coût de la
crédibilité est invité ce qu'une société
considère comme étant le plus sacré
vous êtes intéressant de voir que
justement sur la question des des
infractions criminelles et la hotoie
caractère sexuel l'imprescriptibilité
peut jouer il y a je crois une
interrogation avoir d'autres points que
lula et puis dans le même temps une fois
qu'on a dit ça il faut aussi considérer
que passer assez le temps le temps long
bien sûr puisque quand on parle
d'imprescriptibilité il faut bien
comprendre que parce que la stabilité
parlera pas des infractions mineures qui
peut toucher sur des périodes courtes de
trois ans mais sur des infractions à
caractère criminel
il y a un délai longue qui est celui de
30 ans et il y a je crois davantage à
garder ce système
nonobstant évidemment la difficulté pour
les personnes concernées évidemment de
faire face aux crimes qu'elles ont subi
mais pour des raisons multiples
notamment parce que au bout de 30 ans il
est difficile pour un juste de se
prononcer sur les faits le fait qu'ils
sont trop vieux les mémoires évidemment
se fatiguent les preuves matérielles
sont détériorées il ya parfois justement
là la personne qui est accusée qui eux
aussi se trouver dans une situation
d'inégalité en termes de charge de la
preuve
donc je crois qu'il faut aussi et puis
nous de là je veux dire il ya le temps
long bien sûr qui permet de faire que
les choses sont derrière et qu'elles ne
sont plus pendant vos devant même si on
comprend la difficulté à des cyclos des
victimes parfois et bien n'arrive pas
tout simplement à révéler le talent le
tram qui était subi ils ne peuvent le
faire que bien plus tard
justement c'est pour ça qu'à
prescription et les rapporter à la
portée de la majorité peinera à partir
de 18 ans c'est beaucoup mais c'est
quand même pas mal quand même comme
pour réaliser je pense que là après ça
devient curieux c'est sa fille oui ça
fait jusqu'à tomber bien enfin c'est
vrai que la prescription c'est quand
même faire c'est de faire en sorte une
victime n'ait pas peur d'aller
effectivement porté plainte au
commissariat et là on a un vrai travail
à faire sur la libération de la parole
dont on accueille pour que effectivement
quand ça vous arrive et que ça nous
changerait quoi entendu entendu et
compris que c'est ça qui a changé c'est
que la parole s'est libérée elle est un
peu plus entendu qu'elle n'est qu'elle
ne l'était jusqu'à leur paraît assez 5
le prescrit pili l'imprescribilité ce
soit réservé aux crimes contre
l'humanité l'anti star ac c'est aussi
bien comme ça comme sacré justin bout
peut-être intérêts nous vincent pourquoi
le parquet alors que souvent ces crimes
sont déjà prescrit rouvre des enquêtes
qui veut répondre à ça je laissais
répond vincent mais j'aurais juste voulu
dire un petit mot pour remonter sur le
propos de laurent mazaury c'est vrai que
je trouve que y'a rien on parle du fait
que c'est inéquitable puisque personne
ne peut se défendre face à ce tribunal
médiatique mais il ne faut pas oublier
aussi la carence de la preuve parce que
c'est vrai que du coup on dit mais
comment arriver à le prouver mais ça
c'est pareil 24 heures après l'événement
malheureusement c'est à dire qu' il n'y
a pas de preuve d'une violence
psychologique il n'y a pas de preuves
possibles d'un crime sexuel ou alors
dans l'eure et donc je crois que ça fait
partie malheureusement de la faiblesse
de la réponse judiciaire et c'est
peut-être pour ça que ce tribunal
médiatique est choisie parce qu'il ne
faut pas oublier que dans ces cas là
dans ce qu'on appelle en droit
d'ailleurs le secret de l'alcôve c'est à
dire dans la relation entre deux
personnes
tristement mais c'est la relativité de
la vie c'est parole contre parole donc
c'est c'la comme mon avis il ya une
vraie faiblesse de la justice et je
rejoins laurent mazaury sur la question
de l'éducation qui doit être fait au
niveau des commissariats du reste
pour arriver à rendre cette parole plus
libre et et surtout au plus plus voilà
les plus crédibles sur le seul fait
qu'elle existe puisque malheureusement
il n'y a pas véritablement de
possibilités de la preuve
mais je laisse répondre vincent sur
l'oeuvre sur le reste oui sur le sur le
parquet qui ouvrent des enquêtes là lors
qu'il ya prescription il ya deux
objectifs à ça le premier c'est de
rechercher d'éventuelles autres victimes
actuellement où vous ouvrez une enquête
vous avez la possibilité donc d'enquêter
et donc de revoir ci a pas des victimes
pour lesquelles les faits ne sont pas
prescrits
la deuxième raison c'est que il y à tout
un tas de parquet en france qui ont
conclu des conventions avec des
associations de protection des victimes
et même si la prescription et que la
justice ne peut plus protéger ces
victimes là où leur rendre justice
appartement où l' enquête est ouverte
la victime est prise en charge par la
justice et donc cela justifie que
l'association qui a une convention avec
le parquet puisse ensuite en le relais
et prendre en charge ces victimes là où
l'âge là où la justice ne peut plus
faire très bien très bonne précision
voilà donc ce qui moi ce qui m'a paru un
peu étonnant aussi c'est que bord au
regard de ses titres comme ça un peu
désabusé maintenant aux deux genres à
qui le tour non c'est vrai que ça aurait
fait il ya quelques années une de tous
les journaux enfin une personnalité
accusée de viol ou d'inceste non j'ai le
sentiment patrice que ça bien fait ça
fait mal mais ça fait parler ça va pas
abuser des accusés n'ont pas montré très
sérieusement avec un regard critique
exact une affaire chasse l'autre certes
il ya un pas qui vous annuel
il avait atterri en affaires de pda puis
cette semaine que va-t-on trouver ben
voilà on en attendant on attend la
prochaine révélation prochain livre en
fait faut peut-être regarder livres
hebdo pour savoir que vous vouliez que
les prochains livres hebdo fait beaucoup
de bien
on va passer à l'événement c'est à dire
les déclarations de la ministre de la
diversité frédéric vidal sur l'islam
gauchisme qui gangrènent nitel
l'université alors oui c'était été d'une
interview qu'elle a fait assez news dans
laquelle ministre de l'université a
parlé de cet islam au gauchisme d'audi à
seat qui dit elle gangrène d'université
ça fait une réaction tm squatter 800
universitaires qui ont demandé sa
démission que la conférence des
présidents à lui a reproché d'utiliser
un vocabulaire d'extrême droite que le
cnrs qui est lui demander d'enquêter
justement dit mais islamo-gauchiste
n'est pas une notion scientifique et aux
faux il ya comme ça une guerre de
posture qui fait que ça permette pas
analysé le fond de savoir justement s'il
ya des mouvements alors peut-être que le
mode islamo gauchiste mais peut-être pas
le bon on pourra en discuter mais s'il
ya en effet une représentation de sukkur
on est représentée fortement ou pas dans
l'université qui veut commencer là
dessus patrice mois ce qui
m'intéresserait c'est qu'on entende nos
universités ont produit seulement parce
que j'avais un projet une vision de
l'époque où j'allais les versets mais
c'était un ancien j'en ferais pas après
alors qui veut qui veut en parler le
premier non non j'ai après toi ok merci
à charles m juste un mot rapidement en
fait de quoi parle-t-on quand on accuse
en fait universités ou les
universitaires des tringles islamo
gauchiste on les accuse en fait
essentiellement
de ce que j'en comprends dans les biens
les la terminologie la terminologie en
fait ce qui en effet dans la sociologie
l'histoire et ses différentes
différentes courant d'études c'est de
reconnaître en fait l'existence d'une
islamophobie et de lutter contre
l'islamophobie et ce genre de ce genre
de dérives
sauf que en fait là où il ya un problème
en tout cas moi j'ai un soucis avec
l'appellation le terme d'islamophobie
c'est que en fait l'islamophobie si on
la reconnaissait elle empêcherait en
réalité toute critique de l'islam
or on n'est pas dans une démocratie
empêché de critiquer une religion ce
qu'il faut poursuivre interdire c'est le
racisme c'est toute forme différente
forme de xénophobie etc
donc on ne peut pas être effectivement
que ce soit arabophobe ou ce genre de
choses mais mais en revanche
l'islamophobie ne me semble pas être un
terme adapté et c'est vrai que c'est un
une position qui est poussé notamment
dans certaines instances onusiennes par
les pays du golfe est deja et en
réaction on a eu l'extrême droite parce
que l'islamo gauchisme est aujourd'hui
un terme repris et popularisée par
l'extrême droite même si c'est pas
l'extrême droite qui n'est inventé pour
contrer justement ces propos là et donc
on a une onde un gouvernement qui tombe
dans ce panneau là alors à dessein moi
je veux dire c'est je pense qu'ils sont
tout à fait conscients et c'est tout à
fait volontaire alors comme mon avis
tout ça n'est qu'un feu de paille est en
réalité on manque le vrai problème
toulon prend re marier alors si on peut
reposer la question autrement pardon
pour vous répondre
au fond c'est sa voix et c'est ce que
dénonce un certain nombre
d'universitaires qui sont spécialistes
de ces questions comme gilles kepel
c'est que les travaux des gens qui
dénoncent justement là l'islamisme
dans l'université ces travaux sont
laissés de côté ne sont pas financées et
que ceux qui tiennent les rênes de cet
enseignement sont plutôt en effet de ce
courant d'islamo gauchistes qui encore
pas encore une fois pas le bon bout
c'est-à-dire de tolérance vis-à-vis de
de l'islamisme c'est ça que c'est ça la
réalité
vous avez tout à fait moi je suis un peu
énervé par le commentaire de vincent
couronne parce que cette vilaine
habitude qui est que dès que quelque
chose dérange on va abaisser le mot de
l'extrême droite heure là ça y est c'est
balayer on a pu leur parler de l'islamo
gauchisme parce que l'extranet elle a
récupéré ce n'est pas un terme qui vient
de l'extrême droite et quand bien même
l'extrême droite l'aurait récupéré je
revendique n'étant pas d'extrême droite
le droit de pouvoir parler de l'islamo
gauchisme voilà deuxièmement fait pas si
j'ai pas bien compris ce qu a dit
vincent mais on a plutôt affaire plutôt
une islamophilie à lui à l'université
qu'une islamophobie enfin je veux dire
franchement je n'ai pas vu de d'exemple
voilà donc peut-être que que vincent
s'est un peu trompé vincent il vous
répond vite fait de parler d'islam au
filet ou d'islamophobie
moi je n'ai aucune position vis-à-vis de
l'islam a exprimé publiquement quoi que
ce soit j'ai mon avis personnel sur
l'islam sur la religion catholique sur
le reste c'est mais je ne suis ni
islamophile ni islamophobe
c'est ça en fait on se bat pas du tout
sur le bon second tient là ce que ça
cache en réalité la déclaration de la
ministre qu'elle donne l'impression
qu'on a une université complètement
islamisée et dans laquelle en fait en
sociologie ou dans les sciences sociales
en général les fonds 20 vauvert
l'étude l'analyse la promotion de
l'islam et ce genre de choses ce qui est
complètement faux
c'est ce qui est complètement faux il ya
des fonds il ya des enfants qui sont
attribués à des centres de recherche
pour faire des recherches sur ce qu'on
appelle par exemple l'intersexualité
c'est à dire le fait que dans une
société
vous avez différents paramètres qui
peuvent entrer en ligne de compte pour
utilisent pour analyser ce qui la
position des dominants comme la race la
classe sociale et la religion mais mais
mais mais pas du tout mon monde parle
pas de enfin c'est pas l'islamo
gauchisme cessé de ces de l'étude la
recherche
on est quand même dans une université où
on interdit à un fermier groton interdit
même à françois hollande a suivi à gaz
un ski de faire des conférences mais
excusez moi mais enfin je veux dire on
va pas tourner autour du pot c'est quand
même absolument anormal non visiblement
salaire de 200 guémas en temps je sais
pas ce qu'il dit pour le coup juste un
bout de laurent moi j'ai envie de le
couper en deux le mot en question moi
j'ai connu une époque où les vastes et
et gauchistes taipa islamo ils et elles
étaient gauchistes moi je me rappelle
avoir choisi d'aller à créteil n'est pas
juste siens parce que quand je suis
rentré dans le logiciel pour les
m'inscrire j'étais halluciné des
affiches que vous voyez sur les murs à
japon sont en train d'être ailleurs
d'une part c'était affreux dans le temps
des textes non mais s'était fait fort
vingt ans après 68 mais c'était et donc
on était gauchistes les universités
étaient gauchistes désolé je vois à part
assassin tout le monde le sait parce
qu'ils avaient la garde ou à sa saison
donc donc déjà le premier point c'est
c'est assez étrange en france c'est à
dire que nous prônons la laïcité et la
politique dans l'ensemble du système
éducatif jusqu'au bac qui alors après le
bac celle inverse c'est à dire que après
le bac
l'université devient le la salle
d'attentes de la politisation lors c'est
effectivement issu de 68 tous deux ont
peur des universités parce que -
étudiants sont forts parce que c'est là
effectivement eu beaucoup de partis
politiques vont chercher leurs recrues
pour après donc on retrouve dans les
vers cité aujourd'hui ce qu'on y avait
dans les années 70 ce cercle
effectivement nous aider à cesson je
suis désolé globalement globalement
gauchistes ou gauchisante là dessus est
venue se greffer quelque chose c'est que
quand on a une tendance évitement
gauchistes gauchisant en université pour
exister il faut évidemment aller
chercher les mouvements à la fois sorte
radicaux et éventuellement mais
minoritaire pour en défendre une
minorité pouvoir montrer que l'on
protège la veuve et l'orphelin donc le
conflit israélo-palestinien d'époque se
retrouvent appentis aux universités moi
je vais vous raconter une anecdote
incroyable avec des années communistes
parce que merci j'ai des amis commune
nous allons très souvent au stade
je me souviens tu allais voir france
israël et à voir mes copains qui au
moment de l'hymne israélien ne se lève
pas et n'applaudissent pas j'ai pas
prête à vous dis pas non mais tu
comprends ces sionistes toubib ait envie
d'avoir un match de football
c'était mes amis gauchistes les mêmes
qui avaient grandi avec moi qui
m'expliquait qu'il avait rien porter le
conflit se repaît dessinée en france
donc si les islamo gauchistes c'est
effectivement avoir utilisé cette
tendance minoritaire pour avoir un
drapeau à défendre et grâce à cela
existe et je le comprends il existe et
je partage un ce que vous disiez il est
présent on peut pas le ne peut pas le
nier
alors à partir de là par contre en faire
une règle générale c'est de tous les
étudiants se islamo gauchiste et tous
les pros avec serah non je rappelle que
ces six ans qui ont signé la pétition
sur 91 mille enseignants chercheurs 691
but donc j'ai tendance à penser que
beaucoup d'étrangers dont beaucoup
effectivement de professeurs d'alger
tracé qui ont donné à tous plus donc ça
reste quand même très minoritaire et
après par contre néanmoins le problème
de la laïcisation de l'indépendance en
remettons universités mais en même temps
une forme de neutralité scientifique
devrait être la règle et là où la
ministre des universités vidal doit
intervenir c'est vivement de saturer par
l'appel est lancé des études et enfin en
france il ya besoin de faire une étude
pour il suffit de rentrer aux
universités de regarder sa fille je leur
dis pas besoin de la faire des études
par contre que l'on essaie de remettre
en place pour avec l'église au centre du
village c'est à dire d'abord
l'enseignement la pensée la pluralité
l'esprit critique de tous horizons de
semble devoir être effectivement le rôle
de milices des universités avant d'aller
désigné par dont les uns les autres et
de caractériser regardons la réalité des
choses
c'est vrai que c'est vrai alors
peut-être peut-être encore une fois
peut-être que le mot l'islamo gauchisme
et paquebots faut rappeler qu'il a été
inventé par un trotskiste en anglais
monsieur hartmann qui dit voile a appelé
à la convergence des buts entre les
révolutionnaires et des
la ministre en au coeur du sujet les
banques mais il offre un mois voilà
autant d'enseignants sa mémé est juste
le mot pardon parce que j'aurais quand
même
interrogé en fin d'année et jean
baptiste
c'est vrai que il ya aussi quand même et
vincent va sauver le reconnaître il ya
aussi des mouvements racialiste qui
s'exprime à la diversité du mouvement a
dit liste ya ce qu'on appelle aussi
c'est le mot de genre pour le mode
gilles kepel des des négationnistes
c'est à dire de ce qu'il dit c'est pas
l'islam qui est en cause quand et des
attentats c'est la situation sociale
c'est la situation des banlieues etc
et il ya par exemple un sociologue
extrêmement connue comme olivier roy qui
était sur l'année important qu'ils
pensent à et qui a un poids formidable
enfin très fort dans l'université
alors voilà donc vous réaction là dessus
en interne m alors moi j'ai mis deux
choses qui me viennent en tête quand
j'entends parler tout ça déjà le terme
islam au gauchisme je pense que il faut
vraiment rétablir la position du cnrs
est à dire qu on inspecte pas une
université sur une opinion politique et
sur une notion qui n'a pas de fondement
c'est à dire que l'islamo gauchisme je
rejoins les propos de laurent le
gauchisme c'est encore quelque chose de
très différente de l'islamo et l'islam
au ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire aimer
l'islam ça veut dire soutenir des partis
islamistes ça veut dire soutenir des
propos islamiste est encore l'islamisme
est encore très différent du des
négationnistes donc en fait on est en
train de poser une étiquette était
d'ailleurs formidablement affiché
derrière vont patrice sur sur des
réalités qui ne veulent absolument fin
qui n'ont aucun aucun élément de
communautés c'est à dire qu'il ya du
racisme on l'a vu à l'assemblée
nationale avec ce qui a été dit à yale
pour une pie v cc c'est de
l'antisémitisme
il ya de l'anti islam il ya de tout
malheureusement dans une société aussi
tu disais que la nôtre en ce moment
deuxième point inspecter les
universitaires moi c'est quelque chose
qui me fait hurler en général parce que
je suis venu pour le coup pas du tout
d'accord avec commande sur ce point je
crois qu'on a affaire à des jeunes
adultes et qu' il est donc important
c'est notamment pour ça que le voile
n'est pas n'est pas n'est pas interdit
dans les universités que ça me paraît
très important parce que
on a affaire à des jeunes adultes qui
pensent qu'ils veulent alors est-ce qu
évidemment l'éducation de la pensée à
laquelle on est censé concourir mérite
encore de continuer au delà 18 ans bien
sûr mais après de là à savoir si
justement il ya une telle ou telle
influence jeu je pas si c'est vraiment
le bon propos troisième point c'est loin
d'être le problème de l'université en ce
moment alors de là à être l'échantillon
représentatif je pense qu'en droit
on est sûrement pas ceux auxquels on
pense lorsqu'on parle des études sur le
sur la religion sur la culture c'est
bien plus les sociologues ou les
philosophes qui sont concernés mais mais
je crois pas que ça soit que ça soit une
préoccupation étudiante et enseignante
de tous les jours au contraire on a
affaire une qualité qui est aujourd'hui
une violence inouïe dont je crois
vraiment pas que c'est de ça qu'il faut
parler en ce moment et quatrième point
on s'est préoccupé de cette islamo
gauchiste mais nous en université en
tout cas moi de mes expériences
d'étudiantes
j'ai eu à faire aussi a beaucoup de
professeurs très violemment anti enfin
antisémite ou en tout cas même avec des
propos homophobes qui était absolument
affreux mais pendant longtemps en tout
cas c'était la vague des années au moins
d'étudiants ont dit mais c'est la
liberté d'enseignants chercheurs c'est
comme ça il faut les subir donc à ce
moment là si on si on fait la chasse aux
sorcières il faut la faire à toutes les
opinions radicales et j'ai tendance à
penser que moi quand on m'a appris et
bien non écoute tu es obligé de suivre
l'enseignement de un tel à telle
université dont pousser tous les
familiarités avec tels mouvements
d'extrême droite ou tel mouvement
d'extrême gauche et bien c'est comme ça
c'est sa liberté donc est-ce qu'il faut
pas quand même laisser une place à ce
principe fondamental des lois de la
république de l'indépendance des
enseignants-chercheurs mal moi j'ai
quand même tendance à penser que oui et
à ce moment là à quelle opinion
voulons-nous nous confronter est-ce que
c'est l'antisémitisme est ce que c'est
l'anti islamisme est ce que c'est le pro
islamisme et dans quelle frange et pour
qui et à quel moment parce que étiqueté
tout cela avec un gros autocollant ça me
paraît vraiment très grave
oui mais alors peut-être qu'on peut
essayer de le définir cet islamologue au
site
au fond ce qui est reproché c'est où la
faveur
la tolérance pour l'islamisme ou en tout
cas l'absence de condamnation de
l'islamisme de la part d'un certain
nombre d'universitaires pour des réseaux
qu'ils expliquent d'ailleurs m'enfin
c'est un peu ça c'est quand l islamo
gauchistes c'est ça c'est ça qu'est
lequel pointe du doigt et il ya quand
même le fait que des chercheurs qui
condamne l'islamisme ont du mal à faire
financer leurs recherches
c'est vrai que il ya aussi la question
de l'argent qui intervient là dedans
jean baptiste dû plaire et puis après
laurent amazon et oui j'ai du mal en
fait à vous apporter une réponse était
non ça va peser des je vois vraiment
qu'on est missionné n'est pas parce que
je nous positionner sur le débat mais
parce que j'ai du mal à comprendre le
débat anshan l'a bien rappelé jacques
par l'université car attention
l'université ces universités de médecine
cdu n'a cité de biologie cellulaire
c'était un endroit
je crois que déjà on vise plutôt à la
sociologie est en traitement la rigolade
à cette politique
je crois dans une moindre part sur la
littérature et la sociologie
donc ça c'est le premier point ensuite
sur la formule l'islamo gauchisme
vraiment par l'islamisme mais le jeu
pour je ne sais pas trop quoi penser non
plus de ce terme là est ce qu'on parle
beaucoup de l'islamisme radical est ce
qu ont pas voyez par exemple s'il est
question en fait de parler de la censure
c'est à dire de certains universitaires
qui décideraient de ne pas encourager
des jeunes chercheurs aller sur des
terrains prétexte qu'ils ne vont pas
dans le sens de leur pensée j'ai envie
de dire à la limite que soit la pensée
qui est développée pas ce chercheur sont
sous groupe danois dans sa lettre et
poursuivre soit ce n'est pas le cas tu
vois ce qu'on leur reproche et les
étudiants peuvent alors se retourner
dans d'autres universitaires dont la
vendre aux côtés des sujets de thèses
des travaux qui peuvent se conformer se
conformer à l'ordre
j'ai l'impression finalement d'en
rajouter on veut transposer à l'échelle
des universités un débat politique et
qu'on soit très politisé la parole des
universitaires mais on oublie qu'en fait
la science est justement aux antipodes
de la
meetic alors bien sûr il arrive parfois
que sous couvert évidemment de l'organe
universitaire certains collègues avance
des considérations politiques et dans ce
cas là je pense que ce sont des
universitaires des voix la science et
dans ce cas là il faut les attaquer en
tant que tel mais par les disney mogo
chiche je suis désolé moi je ne
comprends pas cette formule bon alors on
voit bien qu un héros comme l'autre de
laurent et je voulais réagir parce que
après tout je suis un homme politique et
donc je suis là pour penser la société
cdaf est révolue et je ne suis pas
effectivement du tout d'accord avec
charlène sur un point c'est que
effectivement oui moi j'estime que
l'université française alors qu'elle est
financée par la république eh bien c'est
la république qui doit s'y exercer et
non pas autre chose et je n'attends pas
des des professeurs et je n'aurais
jamais entendu de mes professeurs qui
viennent me donnait des cours de
politique quand je suis en sociologie
c'était pas pareil et je n'attends pas
effectivement à ce que si sensuelle
doigté avoir la seule censure qui doit y
avoir c'est celle de la république et
j'estime que les données personnelles et
tout ce qui relève dans les conceptions
métaphysique et politiques doivent
rester en dehors de l'université j'ai le
faire exprès ça m'empêche pas d'être un
jeune adulte est de penser ce que je
pense mais en tout cas je ne viens pas
l'exprimer en tant que profession auprès
de mes élèves
voilà donc ça c'est un point pour moi
important et j'aimerais qu'on ait cette
évolution effectivement elle paraît
complètement et j'entends par avance que
je suis rétrograde par rapport à 68 et
donc doit être d'une autre époque
effectivement sur nous au xxème siècle
puis du siècle dernier mais en tout état
de cause pour me fonder une opinion on
m'apprenait pour fonder son opinion
écoute l'ensemble des opinions des
autres et dès lors qu'un enseignement et
monolithique
alors je prends aussi le point de dire
qu'effectivement on parle surtout la
defa qu'on va dire sur la partie philo
sociaux et que voit le sociologie ça on
est bien d'accord mais j'irai justement
est d'autant plus si je veux
effectivement me font des mots de
pignons je dois avoir accès à l'ensemble
des données du savoir et je dois laisser
les conceptions métaphysique en dehors
de l'université
il ya une certaine philosophie dont on
parlait sont les métaux à la porte du
temple l'université c'est un temple je
laisse les taux à la porte du temps mais
vous vous reconnaissez l'indépendance
des
des aussies ont cherché oui dans un mail
indépendance d'enseignants chercheurs
certes dans un cadre républicain
les enseignants chercheurs ils sont pas
hors sol ils sont pas je sais pas où
saïd ancien chercheur de dubaï
ils sont sous le coup de la république
avec constitution et je suis désolé
c'est une forme d'indépendance mais une
indépendance et pas c'est pas là le
fanatisme religieux c'est page expriment
des opinions extrêmes effectivement il
n'y a pas de racisme d'antisémitisme
il ya un point quand même type important
alors après on peut penser ce qu'on veut
de lui mais l'un des premiers qui a
dénoncé cette cette mise
cette prise de pouvoir dans l'université
par ce cours là c'est quand même gilles
kepel qui est qui et qui
quand même quelqu'un qui connaît bien la
question après on peut ne pas être
d'accord avec lui il m'a fin c'est quand
même quelqu'un qui connaît bien la
question en tout cas je pense que la
drogue juste c'est peut-être simplement
dire un mot c'est à dire que évidemment
tout le monde est sur le coup de la loi
de la république et j'ai envie de dire
de l'ensemble des citoyens donc
précisément l'université également mais
la seule chose c'est juste vous l'avait
dit en début de propos politique c'est
une chose d'universitaires c'en est une
autre
or là on est en train de chasser des
universités peint des idées politiques à
l'université et moi c'est profondément
shopping chauffe c'est à dire que ça ne
devrait pas exister là je suis d'accord
mais deuxièmement comment c'est la même
chose que la loi fait news comment
travailler sur une feuille kns sans
savoir qu'est ce qui est une vraie
information et sont donc du coup donné
un labellisation à ce qu est une vraie
information
moi je suis très choqué par l'idée qu'on
contrôle les propos à un certain prisme
c'est à dire que donc du coup
aujourd'hui moi par exemple je suis
constitutionnaliste donc j'ai un
séminaire de liberté religieuse et des
libertés d'expression religieuse est ce
que je dois le considérer comme islamo
compatible bauchi cette erreur je ne
veux pas me poser ces questions est
précisément je crois que à partir du
moment où on fait rentrer le prisme
politique dans l'université on se trompe
et donc je suis totalement d'accord avec
vous mais je crois précisément que quand
on pointe l'islamo gauchisme à
l'université c'est là qu'on fait entrer
la politique dans l'université donc
chacun son troupeau et les moutons
seront bien gardées moi ça me semble
être un
conclusion on voit que le débat ne fait
que commencer pour le conclure jean
sable pour conclure je pense que la
ministre a vraiment mis le doigt où ça
fait mal parce que à entendre tous nos
charmants université n ya pas de
problème des mots gauchisme et s'est
soumise aux droits de l'homme il m'avait
si l'addition remontés comme des coucous
pour nous dire que ça n'existe pas mais
tout en accusant les on voit bien que ça
existe sinon il n'y aurait pas de débat
je veux dire donc la ministre par des
sarthois de vous sentir comme un coucou
je je je je sens je sens vraiment je me
sens pas du tout remonté comme un coucou
sur ce plateau là je suis remonté comme
un coucou contre les propos de la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur ça
c'est vrai mais pour faire plaisir à
jean charles et pour le rassurer
je ne considère pas qu'il n'y a pas de
problème à l'université il y a quelques
jours
la justice a ordonné un centre de
recherche en sociologie a réintégré un
chercheur un sociologue qu'elle avait
été exclu de son labo parce qu'ils
s'étaient opposés à une conférence à
laquelle participent et une militante de
l'islamophobie et enfin contre
l'islamophobie bon voilà et donc ça
c'était donc ça évidemment il ya
toujours le problème à l'université ne
savait pas de l'islamo gauchisme encore
une fois mais on a vu on avait dans des
universités des conférences dans lequel
on disait que le féminisme de simone de
beauvoir était un fait des bises isme
raciste ou avait invité une femme qui
disait beau qu'une une femme blanche ou
violer par un noir ne devrait pas porter
plainte
il ya eu quand même aussi des dérives et
puis aussi se corroder négationniste qui
est quand même qui semble quand même
important après essai mesuré quand même
si si cette influence est importante et
si elle est néfaste quand même se
justifier il faut là il faut là il faut
non il faut l'éradiquer partout aucune
possibilité dans un discours public
d'entendre quelque chose qui rompt
l'égalité et l'unité des citoyens mais
pourquoi alors ne pas commencer une
enquête dans les médias ne pourquoi ne
pas commencer une enquête dans les
écoles pourquoi ne pas commencer une
enquête dans les supermarchés c'est
partout on entendait des âneries et
les étudiants de penser des choses
absolument rocambolesque
ils sont ils sont bien meilleurs
romanciers qui sont juristes parfois
mais mais mais la seule chose c'est ça
c'est de se dire mais évidemment ces
propos sont absolument intolérable et on
l'a dit en début d'émission on ne veut
pas entendre en tant que républicain en
tant que citoyen tout simplement
entendre des choses qui rompt ce pacte
républicain les jours parce que dit il
faut essayer de marginaliser mais ça se
fait dans dans toutes les arènes et ça
se fait à mon avis par une meilleure
éducation et par une meilleure
socialisation de ce problème et je suis
pas sûr que ça passe d'abord par le
contrôle des publications jean baptiste
peut-être un mot juste avoué puis pour
conclure parce qu'après il faut
simplement un mot rapide pour pour
éviter justement je veux j'ai ensuite
les étudiants pour éviter de rentrer
dans ce débat de ne pas se diriger vers
l'université en sociologie ou en
philosophie mais plutôt dirigés vers les
universités endroit voilà il ya plus de
débouchés se taire quand plus de
charlène il faut bien d'abord un
commencer quelque part et le meilleur
endroit pour commencer sûrement dans les
écoles et nos universités parce que là
qu'on fabrique les citoyens de bonheur
des plus jeunes originaires marché est
le marqueur j'entends bien nous rendre
grâce à ou à la ministre qui n'a pas dit
que l'université était gangréné non plus
par le symbole gauchisme dit li a decade
voilà étudions l'est et voilà mais en
aucun cas elle a voulu jeter l'eau enfin
le bébé avec l'eau du bain il ya des
cariocas
c'est tout il nous reste trois minutes
je vais aller j'aimerais qu'on finisse
avec quelqu'un qui n'est pas soupçonné
d'islamo crise c'est eric zemmour alors
ça fait plusieurs journaux il ya eu
l'express si elle vint l'heure actuelle
qu'il annonce comme candidat aux
présidentielles c'est vrai que la droite
ou la droite populiste ou l'extrême
droite se cherche peut-être un autre
candidat que marine le pen que le débat
qu'elle a fait le bon choix avec
darmanin à peut pas convaincu sur sa
capacité à représenter et house pouvoir
devenir président de la république
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous en
pensez et crédible pas très libre
crédible vaincu
humblement que eric zemmour et des
envies politique luiz a sûrement après
est-ce que c'est réaliste
bah c'est un peu tôt pour le dire la
fectivement tout le monde est sur tous
les ans qui n'aime pas et nous ont dit
oui tu es ridicule 13% intentions de
vote restent pourtant sélection ces
barrières transposant dans le sondage
c'est pas rien d'abord mairie et et puis
et puis bon effectivement tout tout ce
que dit zemmour n'est pas idiot il divo
il dit beaucoup de conneries par moments
notamment sur sur pétain cheveux il a
fait beaucoup de choses mais il a une
grande une grande compétence une grande
culture a la base je sais pas un abruti
ce qui est intéressant c'est le
phénomène est ce qu'on cherche c'est
escoeuilles avons recherchent une
alternative de candidature mais moi je
pense surtout que c'est un très bon
candidat pour la république en marche en
fait parce qu'on aurait dit est acquis
français guillemet le crime
les 13 % ils vont aller les prendre ou
base effectivement pour partir au front
national dont je trouve que la meilleure
garantie c'est de démultiplier les
candidats à droite et l'extrême droite
et moi je serai bien et le maquereau je
me frotte les mains en disant quelle
bonne nouvelle eric zemmour plus à
villabona mais c'est magnifique
parce que justement mais l'intérêt de
mâcon c'est d'avoir marine le pen au
deuxième tour c'est pas de l'éliminer ou
prenez ce sont pas sûrs parce que des
110 n'ayez des sondages qui la donnent à
48% comme observé vincent et jean
baptiste pour conclure là dessus juste
un mot on cherche tout simplement un
candidat à droite
donc je crois que justement c'est ça la
fenêtre sur laquelle on est en train de
gloser aujourd'hui avec le cas zemmour
c'est que tout simplement il n'y a plus
vraiment de milieu entre emmanuel macron
et marine le pen est toute une partie de
la population et de l'idéologie et donc
concrètement en déshérence donc je crois
qu'en fait ça manifeste juste une place
est à prendre
est ce qu'après c'est la bonne vincent
je pense que tout à l'heure on disait
que les médias s'était transformée en
tribunal maintenant ça se transforme en
beau temps en vivier pour candidat à la
présidentielle je trouve que les médias
du coup pour provoque une certaine
confusion des pouvoirs et c'est pas
forcément une bonne chose
oui ça peut être un concurent et un
candidat médiatique et on va essayer
pour conclure la parole ou président du
cler
merci patrice norma peut-être pour
boucler une mission en parler de
l'antisémitisme au tout début je dirais
que dans le paysage de l'extrême droite
il n'ya pas d'antisémitisme en tout cas
dans ces candidats potentiels ou avérés
à l'élection présidentielle ça je crois
que c'est une bonne chose marine le pen
les plus père et zemmour est tout sauf
un antisémite ni pu d'ailleurs qu aucun
de ces candidats
et bien ne souhaite rétablir un régime
totalitaire créer des factions armées je
ne sais quoi donc je crois qu'on peut se
féliciter que dans l'extrême droite
française en tout cas on n'est pas l'un
c'est d'erreurs on ajoute aux nets par
le passé on va se quitter sur ceux de
belles paroles très bien mais je doute
que le président trump est arrivé aussi
au pouvoir grâce aux médias a donc on
est juste en retard par rapport aux
états unis donc soyons mais finalement
fameux le cres et et compass trop les
médias sans les médias voilà donc les le
gameplay et c'est vrai que le populisme
gagne du terrain
un peu partout merci merci infiniment
long mazaury jean charles lajoie ni
lettre morte de cécile cale en calant
cécile callou on attend la prochaine
fois encore très bon roman
merci beaucoup et de charlene li de
duclair merci beaucoup vincent couronne
merci beaucoup jean baptiste du caire
voilà on aurait pu continuer une heure
de plus et bien donc on se retrouve très
vite pour un nouveau numéro de paf
[Musique]